germany's blue chip stock index the
decks climbed to a new record high
during Thursday's trading even
surpassing the 8770 mark the Fed
decision has gone down well Lee the song
deaf it has phones are the Federal
Reserve meeting resulted in a positive
surprise for us investors are happy that
the stimulus program is being continued
and will still pump 85 billion dollars a
month into the market it's a strong
signal and the markets are responding as
you'd expect in the US continues to
print money in the hope consumers and
businesses will keep spending economic
recovery remains stubborn with
unemployment still relatively high at
over seven percent but economists are
divided over the wisdom of the Fed's
policy you phaggots the question is how
much longer this can last the more
liquidity is being pumped into the
market the harder it will be to go cold
turkey and then it'll really hurt I'm
fear critics say the Fed risks creating
another economic bubble especially in
the housing market if lending remains
artificially cheap